Hello, everyone. This
is Isaac Kurtzer, the
Department of Biomedical
Science, Old Westbury
campus, and I'm
delivering the second of
the two lectures on
histology of the skin.
This one is going
to concern hair,
nails, glands and
sensory receptors.
The session objectives of
this lecture primarily concern
the epidermal appendages.
so that will include the
hair the nails and the glands
they're found throughout
the skin we're also going
to be going through the
variety of skin receptors
they're found throughout
the skin appendages of the
skin include the following
hair follicles nails sweat
glands sebaceous glands and
mammary glands all of
those are appendages of the
skin in two senses one is
that they're going to be
developing from the same
epidermal tissue from embryonic
development and second they
are added to the skin like
the arms are appendages of
the body they're a smaller
thing added to the mane
so all of these are added
to the mains they're not skin
per se they are epidermal
appendages the planting
of hair into skin as a
epidermal appendage begins
in the third month of fetal
life and this is when the
epidermis of that fetus will
dive into the dermis and
that down growth becomes a
hair follicle which is
capable of growing a hair and
as that hair is grown as
that fiber is elongated it
will proceed in a similar
way as the development of
epidermis that is there'll
be a keratinization process
where those cells, those
keratinocytes, become filled
with keratin, which eventually
leads to their demise,
to a dead cell. That's its
destination, and that's
what I'm showing as the
cartoon to the bottom left.
So, there are similar developed
programs as epidermis.
the hair follicle is divided
longitudinally into three
major segments at the top
we have the infundibulum
next we would have the isthmus
and the region below is
called the inferior segment
the infundibulum is going
to end at its lowermost
level at the point where the
sebaceous gland enters into
the canal of the follicle.
The isthmus, which is
below the infantibulum,
is going to have its
lower point defined by
the attachment of the
erector pili muscle.
Lastly, I should note that
the inferior segment is
divided into several regions,
what we call the stem, the
bulb, and the papilla the
bulb is where you would
have the germative zones of
the keratinocytes which will
form the hair shaft they
are going to have their
vascular supply at this
papilla region which is this
vascularized loose connective
tissue within which we have
a capillary loop if I was
to ask you what makes a
mammal well you might think
mammary glands make a mammal
okay push that aside let's
just not consider that
what else makes a mammal
probably think hair right
mammals are hairy this is true
another thing is sebaceous
glands those two structures
go together hand and
glove the pylosebaceous unit
so we have this funny creature
on the right a platypus
this is like the earliest
mammal that there is this
thing lays eggs it doesn't
have proper ******* does
have hair and does has
sebaceous glands on the left
we have a poison arrow frog
don't lick this it secretes
substances they're very
specialized but does not
have sebaceous glands the
pylosebaceous unit is called
a mini organ by specialists
because there's a variety of
different tissues that are
coming together coordinated
to fulfill a common
function the image we have
in front of us has a cartoon
side and then real life
section side that i want you
to try to really connect the
two remember we're talking
about the hair follicles
the hair follicles here we
have a section through it
this hf is cutting through
hair follicle here hair
follicle here hair follicle
here most of which we do
not see as the entire length
of only this one on the the
right do we see traveling
all the way up to the surface
and that's just because
by chance we happen to
catch this one and not the
others the hair bulb this HB
which is going to have the
germative zone of the
keratinocytes that will form the
hair shaft this hair bulb
is located within the
hypodermis note how white is
with all the adipose around
it that is a T adipose
tissue you might remember the
erector pili muscle let's
look on the left see the
erector pili muscle starting
at the papillary dermis and
then attaching to the hair
follicle well we're getting
cross sections of that
APM, erector pili muscle
here, which is smooth muscle.
And now let's move to this
SG. This SG are sebaceous
glands because they're
dumping their contents into
the canal of the hair follicle.
You can really see it in
this example right here.
As you've seen from previous
slides, there's a number
of parallels between
the keratinocytes of the
epidermis and the keratinocytes
of the hair follicle.
Both will have a germative
zone from which daughter
cells are born and will become
increasingly keratinized
as part of their terminal
destination. That is,
they'll become filled with
keratin and then they will
become a nucleate as a
result. They're going to
become dead cells. An important
difference between the
two is that for epidermis
all of those daughter
cells have the very same
destiny insofar as they will
look the same at the end not
so but here follicle this
will give rise to six
different daughters the first
three belonging to the
hair shaft the next three
belonging to the internal
root sheath. All of these
arise from the germative
zone, a common germative
zone. They are just
differentiated as the development
proceeds. Now, I want to
point out the external root
sheath, which is the
adjoining epidermis that is
moved on down parallel to
the canal of the follicle.
will be surrounding the
follicle but is not the
follicle itself in the
this adjoining epidermis
that is the external root
sheet there is a follicular
bulge that is going to house
stem cells for this hair
follicle so you could rip
out that hair follicle in
its entirety meaning including
the the bulb where the
germative zone would be
found and you would still be
able to plant a new seed
because that would be found
in the follicular bulge and
that's what's going on in
this cartoon this arrow
going down to point to this
little cellular element
traveling on down and starting
again there are a number of
other important differences
in the characterization
process between epidermis
and hair follicle one the
hair follicle does not have a
stratum granulosum that is
this very distinct transition
zone between a a cell is
about to be fully keratinized
and then it fully
keratinized no not so for the
hair follicle is more gradual
process but by the time
that we have the hair
appearing outside the pore is
fully keratinized another
important difference between
these two keratinization
processes is that the keratinized
cells of the hair
follicles do not deck with
desquamate They remain adjoined
together until they finally
break off, right? It's
not that it's a programmed
sectioning of the bolts of
the desmosomes that connect
them. No, no, no, no. It
simply will break off and
you have to go to a barber
or a hairdresser to do it
or cut it yourself as opposed
to the epidermis which
is naturally sloughs off
now that is for the hair
shaft for the internal
root sheet which is on the
periphery it will be present
up to the uppermost layer
of the hair follicle the
infundibulum for which the
sebaceous gland is entering
so when you have the sebaceous
gland entering, and it
will pour its contents
into that canal, well, you
will no longer have the
internal root sheath. It will
break down at that point.
The three differentiated
regions of the hair shaft
that I mentioned before are
the medulla, the cortex,
and the cuticle. The medulla
is the center most region
and that's only going to
be found in thick hair like
the type of hair on the
top of your head the cortex
is going to make up the
great bulk of that hair
shaft that is going to be
where you have the pigmented
keratinocytes okay the
outermost layer is the cuticle
this is a very thin layer
and the cells are very
flat and they're not
pigmented these are the cells
that you need to raise
on up to introduce a dye
when you say i want to dye
my hair uh red or blue or
whatnot to do that you
would be dying the cortex,
but to get to the cortex, you
would have to lift the cuticle.
As with the hair shaft,
there are multiple layers of
the internal root sheet.
You do not need to remember
these divisions. That said,
I'll point them out quickly.
There's the internal root
sheet cuticle. There's
the Huxley's layer. There's
the Henley's layer. They're
all different in their own
kind, but I really want
to point out that the hemides
layer is going to be in
contact with the external
root sheet. Now, this
internal root sheet, this
four through six, it is broken
down at the level of the
infundibulum when the sebaceous
gland is going to be
entering into that canal and
so it is different than the
hair shaft the hair shaft
does not break down it
does not desquamate but the
internal root sheath does
now the external root sheath
pointing to here this is
epidermis it is not the hair
follicle even though it
has stem cells for the hair
follicle within that follicular
bulge. Now, its basement
membrane is so prominent
that it has its own name
called the glassy membrane.
And it's because of this
tight association between
the external root sheath
with its own very prominent
basement membrane and the
internal root sheath
together that you have such a
strong bond between the hair
and the skin. You can test
this by pulling on your hair.
You pull on it, you pull
on it, and you pull on
it, and hopefully you have
pulled so hard that you
**** them out, but they can
sustain an incredible amount
of forces applied to them.
before we had some cartoons
now we have some real deal
physiological images which
is going to be a cross
section of this hair follicle
as well as from a different
view sections that are at
different levels of the
hair follicle I've marked
these or coated them in color
so the red is going to be
for this red box and we
have blue which is going to
be for this blue box and then
the lowermost level the
black is for this black box
so we can see at the lowest
level we have this HP
which is the hair papilla
this is actually going to not
be the the hair follicle
itself it will be the tissue
that the lowermost end of
the hair follicle surrounds
as inside there but you
would have the capillary loop
at this level you have the
germinal cells which also
have melanocytes you have
the coloration of your hair
right it's pigmented right
well you have the same
process of pigment donation
going on for these keratinocytes
that you do for the
epidermis it's going to be
pigment donation by the
melanocytes which produce the
pigment this GM is the glassy
membrane connective tissue
now moving on up we have
hair which is for this hair
shaft this is almost entirely
going to be cortex we
have the external root
sheath GM is going to be that
glassy membrane moving
on up further we have the
different divisions of the hair
with the medulla the cortex
and the cuticle and then
outside we have that dermis
there are two major types
of hair there are vellus
and terminal hair you see
both in this image of me at
a certain state of male
pattern baldness the remaining
hair that I have is that you
can see his terminal hair
this red stuff in the back
these are thick fibers.
The follicle is housed deep
in the hypodermis and I
would have similar hair for
my eyebrows and for my axilla
and other regions that are
affected by puberty. The
vellus hair is going to be
characteristic of my forehead
which used to have
terminal hair no longer but
it's not completely devoid
of hair there are hairs there
they're just really really
small it's Bella's hair
it's like the hair that you
would have on a baby or the
hair that you have in the
antecubital of your elbow
there is hair there it's
just very very thin it's
distributed almost everywhere
on your body except for the
terminal hair where we
have terminal hair and the
places you don't have either
vellus or terminal hair are
very limited it's going to
be the palms and the soles
remember we were talking
about being glabrous that
they are hairless and then
the external portions of the
genitalia there are three
phases of hair growth anagen
catagen telogen anagen is
the active growth period
this could be for the
hair on our scalp ranging
from two to seven years
and so it's going to
be continuously growing
during that time and
for the hairs on our head
that are terminal hairs
This would be 85% of
them are in this phase.
Cotagin is when you have
an involution period.
That is the rapid
shrinking of the organ like
you would have with
the uterus post-birth.
So it's massive apoptosis
within a short period
of time, this shrinkage.
the last period is telogen
and this would be where
it's no longer shrinking
it's just holding on
by the nails so it is a
rest period that is neither
growing nor shrinking
but in the end the hair
follicle will die, and it
will be replaced by another.
Now, I want to point
out a few last things.
First, this antigen,
cation, telogen sequence is
going to differ depending
on the type of hairs that
you're talking about.
Those numbers that I gave
right here, two through
seven, two, three weeks, 100
days, that applies to the
hair on top of your head, not
the hair in your pits right
you do not grow the hair
in your pits all the way
down to your ankles this is
just not a possibility where
it is for the hair on top
of your head and the second
thing i should mention
is you might remember at
least a couple of these words
uh a t g because these are
greek words that may are
probably not familiar but
antigen ana means up kata
means down and telo means end
so cata like catatonic or
catacomb maybe that helps
the erector p line muscles
are the muscles for hair
are the ones that make your
hair stand on end that means
it makes your hair stand
upright stands ***** a
pillar standing ***** the
erector p line muscles are
the ones that ***** the pili.
How this goes about is
that this muscle which I am
drawing in red, maybe that's
not so good for red on red,
now drawing it in green is
going to contract along this
axis. It's going to be
moving from this length to a
shorter length and the result
of that, now I'm going to
go in blue is it's going
to move the base of the
follicle towards it and so
that is going to lead to this
hair fiber changing positions
becoming ***** in between
that hair fiber and the
insertion of the erector p line
muscle at the papillary
dermis the tissue in between
is going to get squeezed
right and get this that tissue
is going to be squeezed
and that will result in the
dimpling of it this goose
pimpling of the skin the goose
bumps of the skin now
another possible function of
the rector p line muscle is
that by pulling on the hair
follicle it's going to be
jostling the sebaceous gland
around and maybe that also
has a functional effect
of speeding up the release
of sebum who knows if that's
the actual purpose but
that's a possibility now the
last thing I should mention
which is certainly the case
is that these muscles are
under control of the autonomic
nervous system and so under
periods of anxiety they're
going to be active okay
and other periods where you
need to have a regulation
of temperature they're going
to be active they're not
under conscious control the
nails are planted into the
skin at the same time in
the same way as the hair
but just in more specialized
places we of course only have
nails for our fingers and
toes and hairs all over but
both are going to involve
at the third month of a
fetus epidermis diving in to
the skin invading into the
dermis and then forming this
epidermal appendage here the
nail now the proximal part
of the nail the nail root
is buried in the epidermis
and these cells like the hair
are going to become fully
keratinized and actually
like the epidermis so there's
the same destination that
is a terminal destination
it will be a dead cell and
that's why I have the very
same cartoon of these
lemmings falling off a cliff
because that is their destiny
these are all going to
involve fully keratinized cells
the matrix of nails is its
germative zone that will
be the root in the most
proximal deep portion of the
nail where you have the birthing
of its keratinocytes like
the epidermis they're
going to be melanocytes and
merkle cells and even Langerhans
cells in this region of
the nail root now unlike
the epidermis but like the
hair these keratinized cells
do not desquamate so they
are not going to simply fall
off with the cutting of those
desmosomal bolts instead
they're going to be
remaining tightly adjoined to
each other this is because it
is a type of keratin called
hard keratin hard keratin
does not desquamate soft
keratin does so the internal
root sheath is soft keratin
the hair follicle was hard
keratin the epidermis is
soft keratin and so what
makes it hard is the sulfur
content so higher sulfur
content will lead to the bonds
of the keratinocytes amongst
each other being stronger
and that's what makes the
nails very hard indeed now
like the hair there is not
a single point at which the
keratinocytes are
immediately keratinized,
cornified, where they
go from life to death
that you do have for
the epidermis with that
stratum granulosum. No
stratum granulosum here.
Instead, you have a period
where the cells are partially
keratinized and then
eventually no more and that
region of being partially
characterized is called the
lunula like lunar so that
is going to be found when
you're looking at the nail
from the top this crescent
shape like the moon like
lunar lunar the nails are
going to be resting on a
bed of epidermis and that
epidermis is not the nail
per se is called the nail bed
and this nail bed is going
to be epithelial cells
they're continuous with the
stratum of bizarre and stress
spinosum of the epidermis
so this is going to be
underneath the nail plate the
nail plate is the nail bed
for which that nail bed
is epidermis of the nearby
tissue okay it's not its
own and that it does have a
intimate role though because
it's going to be providing
the protective function
for those epidermal cells.
Other structures that are
also for the nail, but not
of the nail. That's a
somewhat academic distinction,
but you'll see what I
mean. So we have this
eponychium, which is also
called the cuticle. You need to,
you know, cut this to have
good grooming. This is
going to be overlying the
nail root. And this cuticle
is epidermis of the
surrounding skin. Interestingly
enough, this cuticle does
not desquamate. So this
is the only epidermis that
I am aware of that does
not desquamate. Very
interesting. And then there is
the hyponychium, which is
on the other side of this
nail plate at the most
distal portion. This is going
to be *********** of the
epidermis that is immediately
underneath it and abutting
the nail plate. So these
two things together are
going to help secure the
nail in place and to protect
the nail root together
you may have been surprised
when i said that melanocytes
are within the nail matrix
within that germative
zone for the keratinocytes
of the nail because like
nails usually you don't see
them colored you know that's
why you you know someone
have to go out and buy
paints to paint their nails
to to create that color but
sometimes it does happen
sometimes you can have
activation of the melanocytes
this is a example of this
that there's a stripe within
the nail that these keratinized
cells are colored because
they have been filled
with pigment. There were
melanocytes that donated
their pigment to the keratinocytes
that then grew forward
and became fully
keratinocized. Now, this sample
was taken from a teenager
who had this for a few years.
I don't know why the parents
didn't bring the kid in
earlier, but suffice it to
say, when they finally did
bring him in, he was uh
right as rain there was
nothing that was wrong with
him and so this example is
called pseudo hutchinson's
it is benign over here we
have an example of actual
hutchinson's sign and this is
going to be increased
melanocyte activity of the um
cells that are in the nail
bed underneath the nail it
looks very similar and so
this is a very bad situation
this is a serious cancer
so you can have dark
coloration of the nails this
melancholia melan no kia but
whether it is something
that is of little concern or
great concern needs to be
determined by a specialist
now we've left nails and
we're back to follicles in a
way because we're talking
about the sebaceous gland and
you might remember that i
talked about them together
as the pilo sebaceous unit
so when you have that down
growth of epidermis into the
dermis in that third month
of fetal life you'll have
a further differentiation
of that tissue that becomes
the follicle some of it will
become the sebaceous gland
and the sebaceous gland is
going to have a similar
sequence in terms of the
expression of cells that will
grow grow grow and then are
programmed to die so instead
of being like keratinocytes
where they're going to
accumulate keratin be filled
with keratin and that is
what kills them here they're
going to be filled with a
product that kills a cell and
it's called sebum so the
sebo sites are filled with
sebum and they're within the
sebaceous gland sebaceous
glands are holocrine glands
that means that the secretary
process is one where the
product is released by the
death of that cell the cell
fills and then it pops so
the secretion of this *****
by this tapping of the
cebocytes is seen in this
image at the base we have the
germative zone of the cebocytes
within the sebaceous gland
as the daughter cells are
birthed they're going to
move forward because they're
being pushed by next daughters
in line and as they move
forward towards the duct
they're going to grow and
grow and grow as the sebum
fills them up and then
eventually they will erupt and
discharge the sebum that they
contain now this is a fatty
material that will oil and
lubricate the hair it might
have other purposes that
has been discussed again
and again that's uncertain
but it certainly keeps the
hair follicle the hair shaft
moistened appropriately here's
an example of a poorly
organized sebaceous glands
there are too many sebaceous
gland for a given follicular
unit and hence you have
the swelling of the area of
the skin about that hair
follicle. It's a very thin
hair follicle. You wouldn't
normally see it anyway because
it's vellus hair but now we
see that there was a hair
there and these are the
sebaceous glands that would
be associated with it. This is
called sebaceous hyperplasia.
Hyperplasia because
there's too many sebaceous
gland. Well, where this is
unsightly, it is happily
benign. It looks like basal
cell carcinoma, but it's not.
Most of the time, it's
going to be affecting
middle-aged men, but
happily, it is benign.
Now we're going to
cover the last of the
epidermal appendages,
the sweat glands.
There are two types,
ekran and apokrin.
Ekran are found
throughout the body's
covering, except
for a few places.
It's a fascinating thing, but
this is actually
unique to humans.
You think of humans,
say, what makes
someone a human?
They think, ah, my
thoughts, that I'm
a rational person.
true? Probably more
or less, but also your
sweatiness, that you have
eccrine glands all over the
place when it comes to
all other creatures that
have eccrine glands at
very limited regions, like
at the paws or the nose
or something like this.
For us, we have it all
over. I find this very
fascinating, and so I suggest
that we could be named
**** Sadori or Sweatman
as opposed to **** sapien,
wise man. Now, moving
back to the other gland,
african glands, in
contrast to hecran, they're
gonna be found in only a
limited number of places.
The armpits, the ******,
the **** ******* region.
So there are, as we'll
see in the next few
slides, there are a
number of other important
differences between
these two glands.
The eccrine gland has a
secretary portion and a duct
portion, a portion where you
have the secretion of its
particular substances by
specialized cells and the
conveyance of that substance
to the skin surface via a
duct. the secretary portion
is found in the deep dermis
or hypodermis that's what
I'm circling right now on the
right you might recognize
this image and the eg eccrine
gland within the hypodermis
and then there was this
ed that was above it which
was the eccrine glands
duct so here we have a
sectioning of presumably the duct
from this plant but that's
not really known for sure
because you have so many
echo glands and you're also
doing this in a plane and
they might not move directly
to the surface so when you're
looking at these sections
here this D these are cross
sections presumably of
the same duct as the actual
tube was moving in and out
outside of this plane coiling
around now the substance
that is produced by these
glands is the common sweat
of the skin that you would
have from the palms or for
the arms and back and so
on and this is mostly water
and some salt and there's
a bit of ammonia but that's
really about it there's not
much protein in there that's
very similar to the
ultrafiltrate of blood or CSF and
obviously this sort of
sweat plays a major role in
thermoregulation by evaporation
earlier the secretion of
the eccrine gland is similar
to the ultrafiltrate of
blood so it's predominantly
water there's some salt
there's a bit of ammonia
and that's basically it the
mechanism of this secretion
is american secretion which
is the most common form of
secretion which involves a
organ organelle fusing with
the cell membrane and releasing
its contents. That's
exocytosis. So there are two
different types of secretary
cells within the eccrine
gland itself that is housed
deep within the dermis or
hypodermis. There are the
clear cells and the dark
cells. And so the dark cells
are the ones that are going
to be secreting that little
bit of protein. The clear
cells are going to be
secreting everything else. Now,
I'm pointing to some dark
cells here, and here you're
pointing to some light
cells. Now, there are also
myoepithelial cells that are
going to be responsible for
the contraction of this gland
that will then push this
fluid towards the top.
And this can be very, very
forceful action because you
can be sweating protrusively.
So I show in this corner
a little cleaner for, you
know, your nose or your ears
if it gets clogged. This
is really the principle
that you're squeezing on one
side and the fluid has
nowhere else to go but out.
apocrine glands like echelon
glands have the secretary
portion deep within the
dermis or hypodermis
unlike the echelon glands
the apocrine glands will have
their duck linked to a
hair follicle. In that way,
they're similar to a
sebaceous gland. But unlike
sebaceous glands, they are
distributed in a very limited
way, found in the axilla
and anogenital region.
Now, the abacum glands have
very wide lumens in the
secretary portion. So you
can see how wide this is if
we went back to the earlier
view of the ecclin glands
you don't see a pore in
the center if you do it's
very small indeed here this
is very very wide not the
duct the duct is just as
narrow as for the epic land
I'm talking about the
secretary portion so unlike the
ecclin gland the aprican
glands store their secretory
portions within those
lumens they've got the space
for it right and so it's a
very interesting contrast
between those and the last
part is that the duct portion
of the aprican gland
cannot reabsorb any product
unlike the eccrine gland
that can really absorb water
in to varying amounts as
it passes by as part of the
recycling and changes with
thermal regulation glands
actually don't do apocrine
secretion they do American
secretion like the echoing
glands so what is apocrine
secretion why do they
think it apocrine secretion
is where you have a budding
off of the membrane like
you would have with mammary
glands and the reason why
they thought these glands
did that was because if you
look on the inner surface
of this lumen i'll go to
a pen right here you might
see that there is i'm drawing
this arrow area right here
and you can look on the
opposite side so i'll do
that over here you can look
on the interior portion of
that lumen that there is
a little bit of bumping
it's like a little bit of
bumps like that they called
those bleds and they thought
that those blebs were going
to become um um a branch
off but they don't and they
decided just to keep the
name African gland and i
have to clarify this in a
skin insto lecture now going
back to uh similarities
with the ecran gland they'll
also have these myoepithelial
cells that are within
the secretary portion and
that is going to be key to
the squeezing of that gland
so that you're able to
move that fluid up and out.
Now unlike eccrine glands
this material is protein rich
and they're gonna have
lipids in there and other
organic compounds and so when
this interacts with bacteria
on the surface it can
stink but it does not by
itself have the type of odor
that you think of as well
sweat from your pet now these
glands only become active
during puberty and that's
why you know a six-year-old
doesn't have to have
deodorant but they do you know
once they're 15 and so there's
very interesting differences
that we have between
extra glands and African
glands talking about the nerve
supply of skin that we've
moved on from the epidermal
appendages your skin's
obviously richly endowed
with many different sensory
capabilities that are related
to the somatosensory system
pain temperature we have
a light touch vibration
and so on so we're going to
talk about the histological
basis of that so free nerve
endings are going to be
somatosensory afferents
like all the other afferents
they're going to have their
cell body and the dorsal
ganglion they're called free
because they do not have a
glial cell investment a
schwann cell investment that
would be kind of uh wrapping
around or associated
in some way if you just look
at a uh free nerve ending
you could not tell just
looking at it whether it's
since uh temperature or
itch or pain or whatnot
that's some specialization
that is within the uh
receptors of the the free nerve
ending but we'll just kind
of classify all those uh
together last thing to
note is that they can enter
into the epidermis so It
can be all over the place,
including the epidermis.
Isor corpuscles are a great
contrast to free nerve
endings because these
have very distinctive
structure that includes
glial cells. And so what is
going on here is this Q
-tip-like structure that we
see and I'm surrounding
has a nerve that's in the
core of it. and all this
other structure that looks
like a q-tip to me are
glial cells that surround
it and together that nerve
and these glial cells
are called a corpuscle
and these are packed away
it's a q-tip right looks
like a q-tip what's packed
away in this shape that
it accommodates it that is
the dermal papilla and so
that's why they're able
to detect fine displacements
for fine resolution a
discriminative ability because
those mechanical events
could be isolated just
to a single dermal pillar
here we have a cross
-section through a pacinian
corpuscle it looks like a
onion when you cut it in half
these are glial cells that
we have on the outside.
In the center core is an
axon that's running through
it. If we looked at it
from the outside, it
would look like a sphere
and then the axon exiting.
They're going to be
found within deep dermis.
This is contrast to the
Meissner corpuscles that we
just discussed that are
found in the germal papilla,
which is very high up
indeed. These are key
to transmitting information
about vibration, and
they're found in other
connective tissues as well.
The phoenix corpuscles are
found within the dermis
and other connective
tissues. It's characterized
by this bag of connective
tissue that surrounds
the axon here we have the
axon exiting there's a
arrow that was placed by
these researchers to really
highlight what is the axon
what is the bag of the
repeating quarter buzzers
and they detect stretch
merkle cells are the last
uh skin receptor that
we're going to be uh talking
about uh notably merkle
cells are not neurons
okay they're uh modified
epidermal cells and they
are found within the stratum
bazaar so this m is pointing
to a merkle cell not
a melanocyte it's a
particular stain for a Merkel
cell. And so you can see
they're at the stratum
Basilar. And so they are going
to be detecting pressure.
They're very sensitive
to pressure. So they have
those small receptive
fields. And they are going
to be in tight association
with a neuron that's on
the other side of the
basement membrane. So there's
like a VIP exit between
the Merkel cell and that
neuron because they will
release a neurotransmitter
to that neuron and that
will form go to that
neuron synapses and then
will activate that neuron
Merkel cells have been
known about for I think 100
years at this point by by by
histologists but they have
not known what is the
neural transmitter that they
release until very recently
so this 2018 that they
finally proved that Merkel
cells release norepinephrine.
I just thought this was
very interesting, this
contrast between we've known
something for a very long
time, but only recently
we're able to show that it's
mechanism. So you do have
release of neurotransmitter
by this epidermal cell to
this afferent that will
have its own cell body within
the dorsal root ganglia
so we covered a lot of
material uh in this lecture
from a number of different
points but we saw that
there are themes and there's
some interesting contrasts
that should help you
organize all those facts
together but for right now
let's just give a summary so
point one epidermal appendages
include the following
hair, nails, sebaceous
glands, and sweat glands.
These all develop from
epidermal downgrowth and are
housed in the skin, deep in
the skin. So hair, nails,
sebaceous glands express
similar developmental sequence
as epidermis. That is
that they all have this
programmed cell depth for or
their characteristic cell.
Ecrine and abacune
glands differ in many
ways and the skin,
as you've learned,
has an extensive nerve supply.
I hope that the lecture was
engaging and informative.
Feedback is always appreciated.